okay let's switch gears a little bit
from the NFL to the world of fortnight
and switch I guess
generations from head coach Bruce Arians
of the Buccaneers right now to the one
of the most famous East sport athletes
on the planet joining me here on the
horizon show on zoom' getting set to
take part in a fortnight competition and
tournament for his LA sentinels is none
other than Booga how are you Booga hey
I'm doing uh I'm glad to have you on the
show let him meet you man I've heard
nothing but great things about you thank
you you got it so um let's get into it
what what are you about to undergo LA
sentinels your home team that people
could maybe even try and knock you out
or off you tell me yeah so pretty much
what we're gonna be doing we're gonna be
playing some for night games and in the
games the person who eliminates me or
the person who wins the game gets $50
and the person or if I win the game and
they'll donate $100 to Cova 19 relief
efforts so that's a begin okay cool so
how many people do you think and
basically so there's a bounty if you
will on you and the rest of the LA
sentinels that I'll be playing in this
tournament yeah yeah I think that's the
$50 for the win in for if they eliminate
me I think that's the money I mean do
you think somebody's gonna do I mean if
there's a bunch of people on me there's
a chance but it's a one-on-one probably
not okay so that's is that you just
flexing your Fortnight muscles right
there is I mean a little bit of
confidence but well I mean you did win
that tournament you won the World Cup
last year how did that change your life
last year yeah it changed my life crazy
amount of ways I mean first I started
doing online school instead of going to
public school uh I could devote so much
more time towards it started streaming
more consistently just a lot of things
came with that right so you got out of
school basically around other people is
what you're saying he started
homeschooling you know
yeah I started doing online school okay
okay um I guess that's the way
everybody's gonna be doing it these days
right pretty I mean yeah I assume so
yeah I mean so man now at this year's
Super Bowl though what's your what's
your NFL team well do you have one uh so
my NFL teams the Eagles but uh sometimes
the Dolphins also cuz that's my dad's
team so I've got to support them a
little oh my gosh
how's your dad Jesus okay so who's your
favorite Eagles player I don't really
I'm not too invested into football I'd
say more basketball okay for the Sixers
are you yes Sixers are my team but also
my players like LeBron because we have
the same birthday so I see like a cool
connection there have you ever played
any video games with those guys
have you ever games with uh Haven no
I've been played with them but I've
played games that they're in like 2k all
the sports games so what is your best
game my best game with that like I'm
skilled uh yeah I mean it has to be for
a night I mean so then what everything
else I've been okay okay what would you
tell cuz I've got kids who are 11 and 9
and 6
what would you mean if they started
getting into fortnight we haven't done
that yet you know I'm kind of an old
yeah you know we're wondering all of his
friends are beginning to play that what
would you tell well what would be your
piece of advice for for somebody who's
doing that yeah so I guess best piece of
advice if they're not trying to get into
competitive or even if they are I mean
just grind creative work on your builds
also depends are they on are they gonna
be on controller or mouse and keyboard
cuz I some of the practice is a little
bit different okay what would you know
what would you suggest
um I'd say as of now I think it's
controller that's a bit easier to use
okay then
mouse and keyboard so yeah we can change
now what is your film study like cuz I
mean how does it relate to because you
know there's a lot of obviously diehard
fans who might think that you don't have
the ability or the forethought or the
acumen that this world has potentially
to to start doing doubles study and
actually prepare how do you do that okay
I know yes so one of the things I do
I pretty much record all my games also
for a night does you can go into replay
files and watch them right but uh I kind
of just watch over what we do in the
game and where mistakes are and what
leads to them and pretty much just try
to correct them so say say we've run out
of materials before the very end of the
game I'm going back and watching like
where did we lose the materials could we
have rotated a little bit better and
save some materials or what could we
have done differently you know okay and
how long how much of a day do you spend
on that I'd say a day you probably do an
hour to two hours if you're getting
really in-depth or if it's like a
tournament that you want to re-watch
because tournaments are probably the
most important to watch over because
those are the main events and that's
what you need to perform in right yes of
course that's so that's that's why it's
the most important to do something like
exactly all right so then outside a
fortnight your best game is what ooh
maybe NBA 2k I think that's my second
game I was pretty good at that okay
and you're the you were what were you
the best at with that I mean yeah so I
think I was just like a decent player
all around like I could play any of the
characters bills and like when I'd hop
on to my park with my friends we usually
want our games we went on winning
streaks you know so but your friends
don't play against you anything right I
mean that's not me right yeah I mean I
don't really play too much against them
on foreign aid anymore I used to play
with them a little bit but it's gone a
little bit harder okay and then what do
you do outside of gaming outside of
gaming I mean right now not much because
of the things going on around the world
so kind of just at home we're on
lockdown right now just buying the game
well and you got your award from Steph
Curry so yeah so Steph Curry awarded you
which award did he give you I think it's
right there I'm not sure if it's the
Sports Awards but I think it's the
Player of the Year okay that's it I mean
where does that rank be somebody who's
obviously as into the NBA as much as
beautiful I'm Steph Curry going give you
yeah that was I was pretty crazy to me I
mean like they literally the year before
that like I'm watching them on the
finals just see them compete against
each other and it's just crazy that he's
handing me like a trophy and it's just I
don't know it's just amazing that's so
cool so alright yeah it's awesome this
is pretty cool so yesterday I did this
with Kurt Warner cuz now that I'm doing
my show on Zoom for a while here I'm
imagining I'm gonna have a lot of
interviews with people in home offices
or trophies all over the place so what
we thought what is behind you right
there I'm gonna start doing it what do
you got so okay so of course I went up
there that's the four night World Cup
trophy that's the big trophy there's the
two little orange ones right there
there's a eSports Awards the other one
was the eSports forwards down in Texas
so okay those are pretty much my
trophies there and and let's get this in
here this is like a booger poster I
guess okay and chair right there that's
the chair that are used in the World Cup
so it has the number on it too which is
really cool
yeah it's pretty much my setup right now
I haven't like added everything that
I've wanted yet but um got most of it
okay well good luck you know I mean so
there's somebody basically right now
gonna join this tournament is it totally
random whether they get you it's
completely totally random where they
where they play you or not or can they
go somewhere to specifically try and
knock you off what can they do yeah so I
mean what they have to do they have to
sign up on a website they have to go to
sentinels GG sign up on that and then
what they do from there I'm pretty sure
they email a code and that's the code
that I make so only a hundred people are
gonna get in the first Lobby or 99 and
then myself but yeah then they'll be in
my lobby and then then we just play the
game out and see where it goes
that is so great and your your name is
bugga why in case this is a news to
people hey yeah so pretty much my
grandpa originated the name back when I
was a child he used to say Booga Booga
Booga and I used to laugh and I was a
little baby so it's a cute little story
and just thought it'd be a cool name is
forever yeah there it is in infamy and
of course less than that hey man
Congrats on everything that's going on
with you they get in this tournament I
personally know Rob Moore the guy who
signing your checks I know him I played
poker with him it doesn't work out for
me very well so if I can't create money
from him you keep taking money from him
okay bugga you do that yeah I gotcha he
takes more money from me
I'm sure but you keep doing what you're
doing man you do it for him and you keep
doing it the way that you are and so
many people are looking up to you it's
such a young age it really is
responsibility that you're clearly
shouldering very well so thanks for the
calling you doing brother yeah thank you
for having me got it that's booger right
here on the Rich Eisen show go try and
knock him off in this three-day long
fortnight tournament that the LA
sentinels are putting on that's right
here on the Rich Eisen show